So we've talked about how to make our
game easy to play and very engaging.
But the best games also need to
reach as many people as possible.
>> For example, our game where we
bounce a ball through a ring of fire
is obviously brilliant, but it's so
new that no one knows about it yet.
And you can't get someone interested in
your game if they haven't heard of it.
You need fans.
So what makes a player a fan?
>> Fans of players that help
spread the word about your game
by telling their friends about it.
And then those friends tell
their friends and on and on.
>> And how can we get fans like that?
>> Well, word of mouth is one
simple way to grow your fan base.
Many developers also do outreach on
social media to reach a wider audience.
But they keep their fans
by creating ways for
them to influence the content of
that very game and improve it.
>> And by making your game better and
promoting it,
fans can help your game make money.